I think the number one piece of advice I
have for a 19 year old is always
patience there's a very big difference
between being rich and being wealthy and
really normally it's predicated on
people that are thinking in a 20 or 30
year window or just people that are
thinking in a 20 or 30 minute window you
were entering first of all some of the
greatest years of your life but you have
right now and timing and circumstance in
this ridiculous ridiculous 50 months
window and not be practical I think
there's way too much wanting it now now
now which then leads to very short-term
behavior there's no nine week process to
make money right there's no seven figure
expert that's going to show you the way
it's [ __ ] hard work you're 21 you can
stay up 18 hours a day just got it you
got to work if you want it doing what
you love is the number one thing that it
never happened to you it's far better
than stuff and it's just any way that I
could get into you to just go for it the
next three or four years you should
eliminate stuff so many of you as you
build something or extracting dollars
out so you can buy Kings oh fat with
like dumb [ __ ] watches instead of
putting that money back into the
business because you're building
something long term as much as I'd love
to right now like boom up like for my
bunnies sleep on the floor any [ __ ]
chicken nuggets 24 hours a day it's just
not that practical meanwhile it's
ridiculously practical for you this is
one you can grind at your highest levels
go and travel go and start that business
that you've always wanted
you're gonna put into trying to do your
own thing it's just going to be your
time because time is the biggest
valuable asset in the world and so I
highly recommend you take advantage of
the thing that you have if so few other
people have which is the ability to do
something right now and the time to
actually execute it you get to live like
one time promise me that you understand
that the land grab of happiness starts
right now